[Musique]
tapas et néfaste qui m'ont baissé
partout quand j'ai décidé d'arrêter de
fumer
[Musique]
je mets beaucoup on développe un cul je
suis à pâté et demi à de café par jour
depuis longtemps
quinze ans jeté à la mer toutes les
cigarettes et toute la merde et pas
rater pour piquer figaro ce menu qui
semble draconien pour certaines
personnes aident véritablement les
personnes avouent a moins envie de fumer
et à se désintoxiquer pour toucher la
jeunesse il fallait la tirer pour
l'attirer un bateau je pense que c'est
une bonne chose est une attraction
suffisant et puis un bateau c'est très
symbolique
on est embarqué sur un bateau on va tous
vers le même port on est forcés d'aller
vers le même port moi j'étais attiré par
le mot croisière soleil gbagbo
le champagne les phares et d'août c'est
comme ça et les croisières et puis en
fait
en fait c'était pas tout ça je dois dire
quelque chose c'est que les gens qui ont
suivi cette cure il y en a beaucoup qui
sont guéris qui ne font plus et j'ai
rencontré des gens qui fumaient cinq
paquets de cigarettes par jour
bout du cinquième jour sûrement très
satisfaite encadrement j'ai arrêté le
nem
qu'est ce que ça vous fait quand je vous
avoue de cigarettes ça me dégoûte un
petit peu maintenant avec beaucoup de
doigté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]